Vsauce!
Kevin here.
Until robots render me and everyone else with
a job obsolete… or make us more human than
we’ve ever been.
Humans have been working for a long time.
We work the soil, we work at jobs, we work
on homework, we hate going to work, but work
can also fulfill us.
Some of us work to live and others of us live
to work.
But should robots do all the work for us?
Where did the modern idea of work come from,
and is it natural?
In the Paleolithic era, our human ancestors
were hunters and gatherers.
They roamed the world surviving on natural
resources for over two million years.
Working to improve their lives, very slowly,
along the way.
Like by cooking meat in a fire to make it
easier to chew and digest or observing time
by marking lunar movements on mammoth tusks.
And the louse put effort in, too, by migrating
from people's heads into their newly-invented
clothes and evolving into the human body louse.
Which tells us that clothing may be about
107,000 years old and that lice are great
history teachers.
When the population eventually blossomed to
the point of making the "happy hunting grounds"
lifestyle unsustainable, people needed to
settle down.
We built simple homes instead of depending
on caves and started to plow the ground.
We developed agriculture and animal husbandry
to take more control over feeding ourselves.
Many a goat was consumed.
This newfound permanence meant that we could
store food surpluses, support larger families
and develop communities.
For the first time, a smaller number of people
could work to feed the population.
Neolithic humans could put some of their time
into new, productive pursuits.
Like move really, really big rocks.
Humans began to realize the potential -- and
the necessity -- of working together.
With each technological advance, we created
new types of work and relegated some tasks
to history… and that’s when it started
to become obvious that some work is better
than others.
Proof of how much people like not having to
perform difficult, unpalatable professions
goes back almost four thousand years.
The Instruction Of Dua-Khety, a Middle Kingdom
Egyptian text in the form of a letter from
a father to his son, extols the benefits of
being a scribe -- a new profession that rose
to prominence with the development of writing.
The father disparages other, more physically-taxing
professions, while declaring that life as
a scribe was the best line of work.
During the Ramesside Period of 1200 BC his
instruction became one of the most frequently
used practice texts for student scribes.
Which means ancient civilization homework
was literally motivation for avoiding certain
jobs.
Language evolved to describe professions and
work, but it wasn’t until the mid-1500’s
that we had the most recognizable word that
defines our role and participation in that
system: job.
“Jobben” in middle english meant to jab
or peck, a small action that’s part of a
larger effort -- which is why a job is just
a piece of the whole.
That whole being work.
Often someone else’s work.
The word “employ” meant “entangle”.
As an employee, you’re caught in the snare
of your job.
And it came to define who we were.
Occupational last names like Carpenter, Baker,
Eisenhower and Cabrera identified a person’s
position in society by their profession.
They did one job for so long that it permanently
branded their family.
A job became a legacy that dictated your path
through life.
Sometimes with heavy consequences.
To ensure future work for their families,
metal grinders during the Industrial Revolution
denied safer working conditions because if
they lived longer, there’d be fewer job
openings for their sons.
Fear of other humans limiting job availability
soon gave way to the panic of machines eliminating
jobs altogether.
The Spinning Jenny single-handedly wiped out
a job that had existed for thousands of years
- spinning thread.
A job so ingrained in human culture that the
term “spinster” was coined to describe
a woman who spent her whole life spinning
thread without marrying.
Invented in 1764, the spinning jenny made
the weaving process so efficient that people
were afraid it’d take their jobs.
Spinners broke into inventor James Hargreaves’
house and destroyed his equipment to try to
halt progress and protect their livelihoods.
Decades later, English textile workers called
Luddites banded together to destroy labor-economizing
technology for fear of being forced out of
work.
Economists now use the term Luddite Fallacy
to explain the fear that advances in technology
will lead to structural unemployment.
What really happens is that technological
advancement causes industry-wide production
costs to fall, which lowers the competitive
price and increases the supply and, in theory,
leads to more input.
Labor that becomes irrelevant shifts into
new areas, and our goods get cheaper and better
as our standard of living rises.
In 1973, it took the average American 97.1
hours of labor to afford a color TV - more
than two weeks of full-time work.
By 2009, it took only two days to afford a
slimmer, lighter, more energy-efficient, High
Definition TV.
We’re spending less time working to procure
food and meeting basic survival needs but
we haven't become lazy -- we've freed ourselves
up to solve other problems.
We’re beating back Belphagor.
The chief demon of sloth and one of the seven
princes of Hell, Belphegor was described by
16th century German witch-hunter Peter Binsfeld
as using the promise of innovation and ingenious
inventions to lure humans into laziness.
The fear was that work-reducing technology
would free up too much time and allow evil
to creep into humanity.
However, lifespans and standards of living
have consistently improved with each passing
generation — which means by today’s standards
Peter Binsfeld could have hunted witches more
efficiently and for longer.
With the advancement of steam engines leading
to electricity leading to computers leading
to robots it’s leading to…?
The end of many jobs.
A natural function of human progression that
has happened over and over.
From the printing press eliminating scribes
to telephone switchboard operators being replaced
by complex telephone and data exchange systems.
Narrator: The equipment that makes this service
possible is among the most complex that man
has ever devised.
Humanity needs technology because human labor
can only accomplish so much.
It’s why large animals like horses were
first used to make up for the shortcomings
of human muscle.
But all animals have limits -- as CGP Grey
illustrates in his Humans Need Not Apply video,
the horse population plummeted after the advent
of machine power, but we still use the term
“horsepower” as a measurement of a machine’s
output.
Narrator: The horsepower unit proved very
useful.
Watt was able to tell mine owners and businessmen
exactly what size engine would be needed to
replace the horses they’d been using.
Inventions help humans overcome our shortcomings,
writing was developed to make up for the limitations
of memory.
And technological advances allow us to use
our labor more specifically.
The industrial revolution marked the first
time in human history that the majority of
people were put to work doing specialized
jobs.
Prior to that, specialization was the work
of the elite.
Scribes copying texts, architects hired for
public works projects, court jesters juggling
batons.
Now, if you want to spend your life reviewing
seagull poop simulators, there’s a job for
that.
But the reasons robots will replace humans
in many labor sectors are the same reasons
that Scottish engineer James Nasmyth preferred
self-acting machines and tools over skilled
workers in the 1800s.
They, “never got drunk; their hands never
shook from excess; they were never absent
from work; they did not strike for wages;
they were unfailing in their accuracy and
regularity.”
Machines are more dependable and consistent.
But machines and robots aren’t human.
And their continued implementation in the
workforce means our humanity may be the most
valuable attribute we have.
When robots are performing mundane tasks,
more and more people will be involved in uniquely
human jobs.
Markets built around human connection and
collective experiences.
We’re on that path right now.
The amount of hours humans work per lifetime
are dramatically lower than ever, and a 2015
U.S. Department Of Labor report stated that
the average number of jobs held by a baby
boomer from age 18 to 48 was 11.7.
Through most of human history, we worked constantly
at one thing -- and now we’re working less
and doing many different jobs with greater
flexibility.
Increased opportunities to work from home
-- and work less -- have improved the family
dynamic by allowing parents to spend more
time raising their children.
If we automate the systems that fulfill our
most basic survival needs, will it finally
allow us the freedom to spend our time the
way we want?
Studs Terkel’s landmark book Working includes
interviews with 130 people about their jobs.
Many felt their work gave their lives daily
meaning to accompany the earned daily bread
-- but others felt trapped.
“I’m a machine,” says the spot welder.
“I’m caged,” says the bank teller.
“I’m a mule,” says the steelworker.”
“A monkey can do what I do,” says the
receptionist.
“I’m an object,” says the high-fashion
model.
But from the upper crust white collar to the
lowest paying blue collar workers - one phrase
is used repeatedly.
“I’m a robot.”
And as always - thanks for watching.
Narrator: We know we are somewhere in the
middle of a period of unprecedented economic
change.
For those of us who view history as a fascinating
spectacle, the prospect of the coming quarter
century is exhilarating.
It is as if we were privileged not only to
see but to participate in centuries of development
telescoped into a brief span.
It is not too early to train your sights on
this prospect right now.
Man: Same old story all over again.
No jobs.
No luck.